voilà cette règle à respecter quand ça
cogne dure et qui fait très chaud évitez
de rester trop longtemps au soleil
portez un chapeau ou une casquette buvez
deux à trois litres d'eau par jour
mouillez-vous la tête et la nuque à
chaque fois que vous le pouvez et mettez
vous au frais régulièrement
rafraîchissez les pièces dans lesquelles
vous vous trouvez avec des ventilateurs
ne faites pas d'efforts physiques
intenses entre midi et 16h faites tout
particulièrement attention aux personnes
vulnérables les deux priorités c'est
rafraîchir et réhydrater déplacez la
personne dans un endroit frais
idéalement avec des linges mouillés un
peu partout autour du corps et les
conscientes n'hésitez pas à lui faire
voir régulièrement un peu d'eau fraîche
mais pas glacée attention si elle a des
troubles de la conscience laissez tomber
elle risque de s'étouffer et elle a
vraiment pas besoin de ça et si elle est
carrément inconsciente mettez-la en PLS
et surveillez-la appelez le 15 même si
vous avez un doute la personne que vous
aurez au bout du fil déterminera qui il
faut vous envoyer s'il faut vous envoyer
quelqu'un et surtout elle vous dira quoi
faire